Dark Souls 3 is coming to ps4 Xbox one
and PC in early 2016
what's up guys I'm actually here at e3
covering the launch of Dark Souls 3
which is a pretty amazing thing well
done guys you were the ones that got me
here so thank you so I'm going to tell
you exactly what to expect from Dark
Souls 3 because I have seen gameplay we
got to watch a 20 minutes live demo of
the game with Miyazaki himself
explaining what is going on how cool is
that
and there's some info in here that is
going to make a lot of you seriously
happy first up unlike with Dark Souls 2
series creator hit Atacama Zaki returns
as a strong creative force behind at the
game's design for the community this
means a lot there's never been a
negative reaction to a Souls game with
Miyazaki at the helm demands
inspirations shine through in the
development of the games and he's proven
in the past that he's very good at
managing a team so the story of the game
will revolve around the Lords of cinder
who appear to be coming back to life
they're resurrecting and it's likely
that these are the beings that kindled
the fire at the end of each cycle at the
end of each game they're people that are
like Gwyn or people like I'll play a
character or maybe it was the countless
lords of light who existed in the cycles
between ours to go along with that lords
of cinder thing there is a very heavy
fire theme in this game you might have
seen this in the trailer the giant Lord
who rises at the end of this cinematic
actually gives off embers and the boss
we fought in the demo appeared from fire
as well and perhaps most notably the
signature knight of Dark Souls 3 is
sporting this warped metal helmet that
looks like it went through an inferno
and melted pretty bad and this character
mean our player character we're pitched
as this dark hero
hunting down the previous lords of
cinder as we make our way through a
post-apocalyptic world sounds cool and
in the concept art we see this black
mass that is likely a reference to the
abyss and the dark so these are all
things that you can expect
but miyazaki says that he wants to
emphasize more than just darkness he
says that the central theme in this
world will be a sense of faded beauty of
withered beauty and that as we explore
this world were going to be seeing the
collapsing wonder of previous
civilizations so you're probably
thinking like how did another souls game
come out so quickly
well Dark Souls three's production
appears to have started a year or so
before Dark Souls two's production even
began so this was around the time that
blood-borne began development it's clear
that from software now has a few very
separate teams working on this game and
that Miyazaki can only work on a few at
the time so he was working on
blood-borne and he was working on Dark
Souls 3 while the other team worked on
Dark Souls 2 so for those of you saying
that they're rushing out this sequel
don't panic too much Dark Souls 3 has
been in the works for a while now
Miyazaki clarified that Dark Souls 3
won't be the final game in the souls
series though he notes that it's going
to be a turning point for the future of
the franchise saying that future Souls
games look like they're going to abandon
the dark fantasy setting and that he's
interested in moving it in a different
direction perhaps he mentions that from
software has worked on sci-fi titles in
the past they've worked on ninja themed
titles in the past so why wouldn't we
see something that moves in a different
direction
just with souls at the end you know
that's a pretty cool forward the demo
that we saw was in its alpha stages and
it seemed to be running at an unlocked
framerate things looked really smooth
however Miyazaki said quite confidently
that they were aiming for a stable 30
frames per second which might make a few
of you groan but that is what
blood-borne has been running at and
blood-borne still looks pretty smooth
it's a bit disappointing but it looks
like they're playing it's safe with the
framerate so we don't get a repeat
Blighttown situation you know
the graphics were gorgeous but remember
that this is a demo and if Dark Souls 2
is anything to go by the demo could
actually end up looking even better than
the full game itself as the demo began
the character spawned in overlooking
this vast city below us spires were
rising from the city you could just see
rooftops and a lot of it looked kind of
blood-borne II in style very gothic
architecture and Miyazaki drew a lot of
attention to the draw distance and the
viewable environment that you could see
if you can see it you can explore it he
said if every building is actually
explorable that would be amazing
also Miyazaki went on to say that he
himself is directly behind the level
design in this game so it looks like
we're going back to Dark Souls 1 and
blood-borne level design which is
fantastic so what I mean by this is that
levels are going to be dense they're
going to be complex it means that
they're going to fold in on themselves
and that you'll often find yourself
unlocking shortcuts back to an area
you've previously explored and in fact
this is in stark contrast to Dark Souls
2 which is a more linear experience that
many players disliked in fact a lot of
Miyazaki's speech directly avoids
reference to Dark Souls 2 rather they
say things like the game world is
similar to Dark Souls 1 or we've taken
the best elements from Dark Souls 2 and
it shows you have to think about this as
Dark Souls one's features with maybe
Dark Souls 2 and blood-borne levels of
polish for example the cloth physics and
particle effects pretty gorgeous just
like they are in Dark Souls 2 and
blood-borne
however the running animation and the
parrying and the back stabs and the
rolling all of it is Dark Souls 1
there's no doubt in my mind that they
drew directly from Dark Souls one's
design there were actually moments in
the demo where a fromsoftware player
would pull off a parry or a backstab and
the audience would let out a gasp or a
cheer as soon as they saw how similar it
was to Dark Souls 1 was pretty funny now
what I mean by this
is that parrying was instant and
backstabs were instant whereas in Dark
Souls 2 these things were delayed no
instant back steps were a problem in
Dark Souls 1 but I paid close attention
to enemy tracking and there was barely
ever a moment where an enemies animation
left him open for a backstab it still
looks like back steps are going to be
really difficult to pull off
in PvE just like they were in Dark Souls
2 which is great
but you're gonna get that instant
gratification of parrying someone or
backstabbing them instantly
so maybe look forward to that if you
like - I don't know Miyazaki said that
Dark Souls 3 is about expanding and
deepening the features and qualities
that make the Soul series unique so we
know that even the subtlest changes to
the combat and the features make a whole
world of difference let's talk about the
major change to combat which is what
we're gonna call weapon arts every
category of weapon be it swords or great
swords or axes or bows each category
seems to have a different weapon art
associated with it a weapon art is a way
of characterizing a different weapon
class to give an example our character
began the game with the short sword
pretty standard right but at a point in
the demo Miyazaki displayed the sword
art that this weapon category by
pressing a button we think its l2 while
the weapon was two-handed our character
raised the short sword horizontally and
pointed it in front of him in a more
elegant motion I'll put an example on
screen and once this was done our
character remained in this stance and
his moveset changed the weapon art for
this short sword now allowed us to god
break an enemy with a powerful uppercut
or close the distance between ourselves
and an enemy incredibly quickly I think
essentially for this category of weapon
at least it gave us two more options in
our move set that were very unique and
different and representative of the
class that we were using because this is
just one example of a weapon art in a
weapon category it seems like you're
going to have a huge variety
and to you further on in the demo the
player picked up a great sword and it
was huge think this vai Honda from
previous games and even a little bit
longer than that it was pretty big and
you'd think that would make our attacks
slower right but you'd be wrong the
player character displayed the weapon
art for the great sword and oh man it
just makes the weapon so much more
viable great swords now have these quick
staggering Bosch attacks that were
followed up with a giant swing and the
second webinar seemed to be a charged
wind-up uppercut attack that sent
enemies soaring through the air
you know how in Dark Souls 1 the Black
Knight enemies could send you twisting
into the air it was kind of like that we
used it against a knight with all his
armor on and it completely messed him up
Miyazaki mentioned that great sword
wielding is now directly inspired by
guts from berserk this is the guy who
wields a massive sword that he swings
with ease and expertise and I put a few
shots of that on screen because if you
think about great sword wielding from
previous games where kind of like just
putting all our weight into that weapon
and its wings we don't even use much
skill we just swing it from side to side
you know so it's cool to see that great
swords are going to look a bit more
elegant in their movesets as we went
through the demo actually revolved
around the weapons that we found there
was a lot of emphasis on weapons because
that's what Dark Souls has always been
about it's been about this depth of
customization and making your knight
feel like your own the next item we
picked up was the Legion scimitar z'
plural it was one equippable weapon but
once you equipted you were holding to
scimitar x' their special moves appeared
to be this elegant spin that decimated
the next group of enemies we came across
there was this bunch of enemies running
at the guy and Miyazaki was saying how
oh yeah this guy usually fails at this
part but then he just dual wielded the
scimitar z' and did this amazing spin
attack that just took them all out so
that was probably the weapon art for the
scimitar z' and i get the impression
that some of these are customizable
we kind of need more information on
but next up we found a bow and you know
I said that the great sword was inspired
by guts while the bow was inspired by
Legolas from Lord of the Rings and
you've seen how fast Legolas can fire
that thing right no joke the character
in this game was firing the bow at least
twice as fast as bows from previous
games where in Dark Souls 1 you would
have just pulled back the bowstring you
would already hit the enemy in Dark
Souls 3 and I believe that the weapon
art or at least one webinar for the bow
allows you to be more agile in your
movement while you're attacking so
you're kind of running around the level
and firing off arrows although that is
just speculation and rumor from me so
let's finish with a talk about enemies
early on in the level we came across the
corpse of a stone dragon that had fallen
on the ramparts it looked similar to the
slumbering form of sin in the sunken
Kingdom except this one was grey with
ash floating off into the air he
actually clarified that it was a stone
dragon which obviously is a reference to
Dark Souls one and twos law later on a
live stone dragon came down and breathed
fire all over an area which prevented us
from passing and Miyazaki said that it
was one of his favorite things to put a
dragon in an early level the dragon
adjusted its flame to block different
parts of the level which made timing an
important factor when progressing past
it
there were also a couple of times in the
demo where the player was caught off
guard by a surprise attack
you know how in Dark Souls 2 there was
often an enemy that was pretending to be
dead and as you walked past it it would
come up and stab you from behind that
happened a few times
albian obviously the guy knew it was
going to happen and it was just for show
later on we also threw fire bombs to
explode a bunch of barrels where enemies
were just sitting around stuff that's
pretty standard stuff you're pretty used
to at this point if you need to imagine
what this level was like you just need
to think about boletaria one one from
Demon Souls or the undead burg from Dark
Souls 1 you know it was filled with
hollows hollow soldiers a dragon some
crazy dog enemies that were difficult to
defeat and the occasional night that was
like the red iron
or the blue-eyed night from demon souls
it was almost like a mini-boss halfway
through the level the night enemies in
particular were pretty interesting their
armor was a perfect example of how the
game's colors actually look a bit more
saturated in Dark Souls 3 with their red
flowing cloaks and brightly shining
armor which made a good use of the
lighting when they fought you their
tracking and movement was fantastic they
rarely presented your back to you and it
still looked pretty natural it wasn't
like they were just spinning on a dime
or anything like that and most
importantly these enemies actually
switched between to handing and one
handing their weapon just like you do
which was really cool I love that
element whenever it's in a souls game
because it feels like you're on even
footing with the enemy so that was
fantastic to see some enemies did some
pretty unique things
there was this one Hollow on a rooftop
that had this enormous black mass erupt
from his right shoulder which was
constantly changing form and attacking
you at the same time the black mass that
erupted was like water it was constantly
changing shape and in the moment that it
looked like it had formed into a
creature with a head the next moment you
would be doubting yourself because it
would bring that head down on you as if
it was a limb and smash you to the
ground the player died here and it
didn't look like it was on purpose and
as a side note when he defeated a
difficult section he would praise the
Sun that's right its back the room
erupted in cheers when he did that and
we fought a boss at the end of the demo
I really wants to talk about it we
entered this large Cathedral
we walked forward and then we picked up
a soul of a great night a cutscene began
and behind us from cinders this being
materializes it was about twice the size
of the player character really thin and
its armor for its skin was this midnight
blue and it also had these elongated
limbs that grasped a whisper thin long
curved blade of red-hot steel Miyazaki
called it the dancer of the frigid
wastes but maybe it was frigid valley I
might be getting that wrong however the
most important word here is dancer
that word fits the way this thing moved
it attacked in these complex dance like
movements and it was quite difficult to
decipher where it was going to hit it
moved like water and its limbs were
always curving and flowing it never had
any real sharp or jarring movements and
I've never seen a enemy in a Souls game
move quite like this music he went on to
explain that all bosses have at least
two phases and as the dancer pulled out
a second blade with a bluish grey tinge
we realized that the second phase had
begun and now it was dual wielding and
attacking pretty much twice as fast
this blue blade was called a blade of
ash and all the while during the fight
wherever the enemy hit it just left fire
in its wake and halfway through the
fight the floor was on fire the pillars
were covered in flames and places that
looked like they were safe to hide
behind now looked like a hazard more
than anything it was a pretty impressive
fight and that's pretty much all I could
remember so throw me some questions in
the comment section below and maybe
you'll be able to jog my memory a bit
I'm sure there's some stuff that I
missed that I could tell you guys but
thanks so much if you liked the video
and thanks for watching I'm glad I could
create something while I'm staying back
sick in my hotel here but cheers guys
here's to more Souls games headed by
Miyazaki and I'm seriously excited also
thanks to Namco Bandai for sending a
bunch of the community out it's great
that they look after their fans and
don't just want to rely on traditional
media to get this info out to the
community but I'll get some videos up as
soon as there's some more info and I'll
see you guys in the next one